主制来做交易
它有一些美感
你要怎么看
怎么买
去到怎么通知你
通知你之后你该做什么事
你看到了浪子回头你该怎么办
例如说你在5月20号
你会看到很多浪子回头
因为5月20号那天大盘最弱
大盘那天跌破了月线
5月20号那天
我是做什么事情
我不是把股票全部砍掉
我股票全部砍掉
我就沒有這一段了
20號以後賺更多
再講一次
我有一堆都是21號以後賺的
賺了2800元
那在這天我們要做什麼事呢
在這天呢我們要做換股
就是呢
要把一些股票換掉
為什麼因為你在這天你可能會接到手軟
所以呢你必須要做點換股
那你只要有做換股的話
你比較
你比較舒服好不好
你心裡面比較舒服
你至少還抱得住
你假如沒錯換股在這邊全部停損
在這邊這一天有人全部停損啊
為什麼破月線全部停損
全面停損
也不能說他錯啦
他搞不好有一次是對的
但是呢
在我們的做處置的股票裡面
破月線他大部分是個買點
他通常不會停損
所以呢
你假如在這裡
在這裡他是個空頭股票破月線
我覺得本來就該停損
但在儲置股裡面破壹線
反而是個大買點
所以我在這邊買了一堆
那我就在這四天呢
就大獲全勝
你看這四天呢就賺了兩千八千也有很大的原因是因為這四天一堆股票大漲嘛那當然是我们这四天的获利就比较丰厚嘛那这些方法都有教各位
不管是在处置里面的课程
在处置神器里面的这个实体课程
我们是随着神器里面它有影音课程
有实体课程
还有每个月的陪跑
所以各位你加一加你是得到非常多个小时的教学
所以你说它贵呢
事实上它有很多个小时教学
还有宝贵的经验
那这一份经验呢
我们会持续的去优化这个软件
我们要打造这个全台算最准的一个处置神器
我们为什么可以有这个信心呢
就是我们现在可以盘中即时算
盘中即时算
其实要盘中即时算了
可能是有点困难的
那什么叫陪跑呢
陪跑是这样子
我们每个月呢
都会录一段影片
来跟各位分享一下我这个月做怎么样啊
我们看一下这个月的储置股票涨怎么样啊
那你把每一档储置股票看一遍
然后再回答一下这个月学员的问题
学员的问题一堆啊
你会买完之后你会
小哥陪着我做这个交易
那我们就可以看小哥最近做的顺不顺
那一直以来我们大概在5月19、20号那两天是蛮不顺的
因为那两天很多储置股都大跌
蠻不順的
但是在不順的時候
我們有不順的做法
不順的時候我們就換股
我們把那個跌的沒那麼慘的
換成跌的更慘的
那因為你這個換股之後
這個因為跌的更慘的反彈更兇嘛
所以你就是你再去挑一些股票
更審慎的挑啦